-Sorry, but I cannot stop
thinking about the other night
-Neither can I.
It was a mistake.
I never should --
It was a colossal lack
of judgment.
-Well, most
good things are.
-Look, I've made
bad decisions in my life.
Kissed the wrong man,
trusted the wrong friends,
but all of that is nothing
compared to what I did with you.
-It meant a lot
to me, too.
-Welcome back to
"Late Night."
We're here
with Catherine Zeta-Jones.
So that is you with the
wonderful actor Michael Sheen,
who I knew is Welsh,
but I did not realize
is from your same hometown
-Yeah, I'm with this
little pimple
called Swansea, South Wales,
and not on the map.
Yes. And the crazy thing is, i
that we have mutual friends --
school friends,
like from, you know, school.
And my parents know his parents,
but we have never met.
And my -- the bucket list just
seems to get heavier and heavier
as I get older and older.
He was in there because
he was one of those actors -
first of all,
because he's from my hometown,
so it's like his family even
though he's not.
You know, he's not.
And he's just a wonderful actor.
And so when this project
came up,
producers asked me
if I would be interested.
And I said,
I love the show "Prodigal Son"
I'd watched it
because of Michael -- because,
you know, it was like,
there's so many good --
there's a lot of good show
on TV.
But I did watch that
and the whole first season
and, because of Michael,
and then --
and so I got the opportunity
to create this character,
you know, towards the end
of the second season,
and they pitched me
something really great,
which is like the bad doctor
You know, it's so much fun dow
that darker side
of human nature to play with
And we had a blast, you know
because we play Americans
in the show,
but as soon as they say cut,
we kind of revert back
to our childhood,
you know, like in-jokes,
people that we know,
impersonations of Welsh people
sayings -- very Welsh saying
that nobody else would know.
But it was so different to com
into an established season
but for me, it's always like
the first day of school.
Every time I go on a film set,
I'm always like...
"Oh, I hope I'm OK.
I hope they don't, you know.
So to have him there kind of
broke the ice completely for me,
and it's -- I've had
a real blast doing it.
This -- this character
has been -- it's been grea
because I've never really done
a show where it's so immediate
Like, I got a script
and I had just the colorin
of where it was going to go,
and then you kind of do
take the parachute off
and throw yourself in a bit,
and you don't know
where -- you kind of know
where you want it to go.
And so you're always, like
on the edge,
like, everything's
boiling underneath,
and then when you see the
script, you go, "Okay. Okay.
Let's let loose on this way,
on this direction,
and it's been -- it's been -
it's been fun.
And I must say,
you're shooting during COVID -
I'm thrilled to be part
of a of a production.
People are going --
coming to work.
Kudos to the production.
I feel super safe.
Protocol, you know.
So it's just what I miss
is the camaraderie.
You know, I like to kind of hang
with the actors and bitch a bi
and, you know,
watch what the crew is doing
and, you know, chit chat about
maybe -- maybe run lines
every now and again, you know,
but -- and so I miss
that part of the process,
but it's -- it's been great.
It's been -- I've had a lot of
fun with this character.
I don't know,
maybe I should be destined
to play bad people
for the rest of my life.
-Well, we do enjoy when you play
bad people.
Mostly because it shows
are incredible acting skill,
because we, of course, kno
you to be such a good person
I do want to ask as well,
obviously,
you've been someone who ha
a background in theater.
You've been on Broadway.
I think a lot of us
are very anxious and eager
for Broadway shows to return
Is that something
you'd want to do again?
-Yes, absolutely. First of all
I say a little prayer
for my Broadway family
because unlike the film crew
around the world
or around the city, in New Yor
or around the states,
they haven't been so fortunate
You know, when
those lights went out,
they really went out,
I mean, pitch black.
And so, I can't wait -- as -
just as a theater goer
and lover, but as a performer,
I'd love to get back on
Broadway.
After I did "Chicago,"
of course,
I was offered every high kic
and jazz hands --
everything ever written.
You know,
"Could you kick a leg
in this show?" Yeah.
I'll see if she'll do it.
And then I was -- I was offere
things that I should be like
90 years old doing,
you know what I mean?
Like Carol Channing
should have been doing it.
Oh, let's ask Catherine becaus
she was just in "Chicago."
But anyway, so when I did --
when I won the Tony
for "A Little Night Music"
it's Stephen Sondheim,
but it's really a play to music.
It's not high-kicking,
is what I call.
But I would love
to do another musical,
but I think my priority
would be a straight play,
But both of them, whichever --
whichever genre it is,
I don't really care.
I'd like to do
something original,
something that hasn't been
done before,
because in theater, no matte
how good you are,
as you know, Seth, it's like you
always got some grandstanding,
"Oh, darling, I saw
Angela Lansbury
do the original."
You know, and I was like, OK
you know,
but you never -- you're always
going to be associated
with somebody's favorite.
And so to create a character -
well on film, it's different
but on stage,
to have a new piece of new pla
or new musical --
maybe a rock musical,
because that would then feed
into my want to be Bono thing.
To have something fresh and ne
that you can put
a stamp on it --
that you don't have to
spend your life
saying sorry for not being
as good as Angela Lansbury
-Yeah, well, I say
that I understand,
as someone who took over for
Tina Fey on "Weekend Update"
-I know, darling, I always jus
wonder why you cut your hair
I liked it -- you know,
it's like why?
-Thank you.
We're going to start growing i
out again.
I always love --
I always love so much --
you -- I'm not going to say it
right.
Because when I when I did
my Saturday Night Live,
which was the most
amazing experience of my life.
Terrifying but amazing --
like, the most adrenaline rush
You, of all the fabulousness
there
and the creativity
and the writing,
you were so genuinely supportive
and fun,
and pulled me along,
like, put your hand down,
lifted me up out of my
terrified...
-[ Laughs ]
-And made that experience
really one of the most
memorable weeks of my life
-That's so nice
of you to say,
because I was terrible
to most people.
-So...
-Yeah, I heard that.
That's why -- this is why
I was so profoundly affected -
I don't know what was wrong with
me that week, yeah.
-You must have been on crack
-I think it was -- that wa
the week I did crack.
-That's the week you did that.
-The week later that I quit it
that was when I was
a real problem to be around.
Thanks, Catherine. It's always
such a delight to see you.
I really appreciate you.
-Lovely to see you.
Lovely to see you. Be well
-"Prodigal Son" airs
Tuesday nights on Fox.